Star Wars has been at the cutting edge of specialeffects.
Puppets, prosthetics, animatronics, CGI... and now, thankfully, animatronics again.
When thefacial expressions go, or the limbs move in, it's almost like a little symphony you know.
It all comes together in a very magical moment.
To create the Star Wars world, we have to createmonsters that inhabit these strange alien worlds.
Gustav's been making monsters for three decades,and he's taking a look back at his creations.
I made many creatures...
Admiral Raddus
Six Eyes
L-O-S-D
Admiral Ackbar
The head of Maz.
Take us back to the beginning.
Where did it all start?
I remembervividly my dad taking me to see 'Return of the Jedi' in Tuschinski cinema in Amsterdam when I wassix years old.
That film sort of lit a spark in me.
First of all I was just in awe, overwhelmed andit made me extremely curious how they crafted these films...
How they can physically make somethingthat realistic.
I just took it all in, and I think that sort of slowly prepared me for myfuture career.
I would read up on books, magazines.
I started experimenting with rubber heads, hobbyclay, plaster, wood, anything...
And put them in my room as ornaments, you know, I just kept churning themout, trying to perfect my style.
So how does it work?
It's a lengthy process.
From scripts it goes tothe design department, and then that mould lands on my desk.
I insert clay to createthe skin.
Within that, I build my animatronics.
Every hair has to be perfect.
The movementhas to be near perfect.
You can only do so much with the rubber skin.
That sounds likea lot...
When I take a creature on set, my anxiety levels are through the roof
just because I knowwhat potentially could go wrong and how much is riding on it so I'm just hoping it's good.
And itgoes beyond Star Wars...
'Hitchhikers' I did Jeltz.
'Charlie and the Chocolate Factory' I did the
squirrels that listen to nuts.
And they asked me tobuild a swimming Oompa Loompa.
I remember not beingable to sleep because I was so nervous becausemechanics, electronics and water don't mix.
Did itwork out okay?
The moment comes that we're shooting it.
Tim Burton says 'Action'.
The kids run in, run to thetank, and they say 'yep, release the Oompa Loompa.'
'Switch it on, swim through frame.' He says, 'Cut, we gotit.'
That was one of them moments that I felt like I was walking on air.
Gustav's done his fairshare of creepy horrors too...
There was this small Finnish film I did and the creature we built - thatwas very prominent in the film.
It was almost like a throwback to the 80s, you know, we're on thefloor with rods and doing everything in our power to bring this thing to life.
The blinks are stilllinked up.
You can hear the buzzing noise.
There was a mechanical jaw and a mechanicaltongue, which was a nice little extra.
So after 30 years in the job, what's the secret?
It's all about replicating the organic movements that you see in nature.
That's the art ofanimatronics.
It's breathing life into a rubber skin to see one of your creationson a big screen.
That's what you do it for.
[Music]